hu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous montrer avec
une grippe comme on fait un baiser de
cinéma et je vais former des couples ici
et vous allez essayer de faire comme
francis ingles basse que dans l'appentis
ambras déjà il ya un couple que je vends
et tout de suite série cabanon
montrez nous comment il faut faire ils
vont essayer de faire la loi surtout
qu'il est très très très habile en la
matière non c'est vrai francis 76 ans
francis oui allez-y alors puisque ça
vous ferait même qu'est ce que ça vous
fait déjà mon avis ça va nous faire rire
vous êtes faute en touche j'ai choisi
mathieu hu
[Applaudissements]
allez alesi et galocher la meinau
kaka mais tout le monde a quelqu'un paye
pas fana pas quelqu'un
c'est ce qu'elle est en train de faire
pendant que je suis tranquillement
direct dans sa mission
ah oui oh la la
mais
la bateau les attendait mais même leur
bisous et ringarde
non mais sans rire odile et qui viennent
le hohneck arrêté environ 30 ont enlevé
mouassa géré ou non mais on dirait
qu'ils viennent de blabla est de bien
répondre nos amours salut tu vois je te
l'avais dit que c'était dans la salle de
bar dit la vérité journal si j'ai pas je
vais tester
[Applaudissements]
si ça vous gêne vous dire votre votre
gêne oui non et bizarre
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
arrêtez vous ai dit ma devise c'est sec
sur les lignes a rien de sexuel là
dedans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allah
quel [ __ ] sept motards
[Musique]